in spite of don phillips living in
brazil he was very close to both his
sister and his brother in the uk they
were in direct contact all of the time
really even on the trips that he
frequently took in the amazon because
he's writing a book
currently at the moment and they've
described to me that they feel anxious
desperate worried but still hopeful that
both dom and his guide will be found but
they are concerned for their safety
dom is a freelance journalist who is
shining a light if you like on a very
politically sensitive issue in brazil
involving the struggles of the
indigenous people there
against deforestation
and
illegal logging and the family believed
there was also drug traffickers in the
area when the two disappeared as well so
they are
very concerned and
this is what sean uh his sister had to
tell me and she was interviewed
alongside her partner paul
he's lighting up a highlighting
spotlighting this area
and i want i want the eyes of the world
on it and i want
him and bruno to be found
yeah but our worry is that that have
been they've been abducted by somebody
who uh who wanted to silence the
the exposure that they were bringing to
illegal activities in the area
he's full of vitality i see him you know
as a he's my older brother i look up to
him i love him
dom's sister really feels that every
minute counts in this case and given
those political sensitivities with what
he was doing they don't feel like the
brazilian government is doing enough to
find the men at the moment they feel it
is only the indigenous communities
searching for them at the moment
they're not having any direct contact
with what is going on with the
authorities there and they want to see
the brazilian army brought in to try to
find the men i did ask them what contact
they'd had with british authorities and
they said that the family here in the uk
had no direct contact with them that
they hope that the british authorities
will be doing all that they can
to help